pour la présidence de l'ump il faudra
dorénavant compter sur un nouveau
candidat henri guaino le député
sarkozyste de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines
il s'en est expliqué hier lors de sa
présence à l'inauguration du centre
commercial el farouk les sous bois
pour lui c'est un autre discours aux
côtés des ténors que sont françois
fillon et jean françois copé
d'abord je trouvais pas mon compte dans
les discours des différents candidats
deuxièmement parce que je pense que le
tête à tête n'est pas bon
lorsque cette il est important qu'ils
aient pas seulement deux candidats
3 j'ai envie qu'à l'ump on entende la
voix du gaullisme très bien il ya
beaucoup de familles politiques
différentes il ya des centristes et des
libéraux des humanistes ou sont de
sensibilité la seule finalement qu'on
n'entend jamais ou très peu sa
sensibilité gaulliste et placement une
situation paradoxale pour l'ump des
yvelines la présidente départementale
valérie pécresse soutien de son côté
françois fillon valérie pécresse a fait
un choix qui est le sien j'en fais un
autre qui est différent mais qui est
australien
au choix d'henri guaino la députée des
yvelines n'a pas souhaité réagir
il reste deux semaines ancienne plume de
nicolas sarkozy pour obtenir ces 8000
parrainage l'élection du président de
l'ump prévue lors du congrès les 18 et
25 novembre